[Music]
well welcome back to another episode of
the addie hour it's always my honor and
privilege to host these conversations
and today i'm grateful to be able to
host jeremy lin and esther chu for a
conversation about mental health race
wellness and
culture in aapi communities
so these are two individuals that likely
need no introduction to you all's
listeners i'm going to go ahead and give
them a brief introduction anyway
starting out with esther 2 dr 2 is a
physician and popular health science
communicator she's known as bold and
innovative voice on gender and racial
equity in healthcare and she's also an
advocate for new frameworks for building
positive and productive workplaces
she graduated from yale university as an
undergrad also went to the yale school
of medicine for med school and currently
has an nih-funded research program where
she's looking at health services and
health policy as a researcher
she's also the founding member of times
of healthcare
she has also been very active in the
pandemic as well where she's helped
raise awareness about the critical
shortage of personal protective
equipment or ppe in hospitals
she also is the chief medical officer of
jup which uh builds mobile healthcare
units someone who's been very active in
a lot of different roles
she also has numerous commentaries which
regularly appear in different places
including the new england journal of
medicine the harvard business review nbc
think self quartz and the washington
post
she's also a regular uh columnist for
the lancet and she regularly appears on
cnn and msnbc so someone who is deeply
invested in a lot of different spheres
of influence and who continues to make
an impact within her profession and in
the general community as well so i'm
honored to welcome dr esther to that
hour podcast thanks for being here
thanks for having me on
of course
the second guest i'd like to introduce
is none other than jeremy lin
jeremy is a pal alto native and of
course is one of the few asian americans
to ever play in the nba prior to his nba
career he actually played four seasons
at harvard where he was an all ivy first
team selection two times both in 2009
and 2010.
as a yale professor i'm giving him a
little bit of grace for playing for the
other team uh partially because he
played for a coach amateur who's also a
dude graduate as i am myself so i
couldn't help myself i had to throw that
in there
but jeremy as many of you all know is
someone who after uh being undrafted and
playing the nba for a couple years rose
to
a level of stardom as lynn sandy took
off as an overnight sensation i actually
remember the game that he played
against the new jersey nets i remember
seeing that in real time and just um
having known who he was over the years
was really excited to see what was
happening in that moment he of course
has played for lots of different nba
teams including the warriors the knicks
and the rockets he's currently playing
for the beijing ducks and the 2021 to
2022 season and i believe you all are in
the playoffs so i want to wish him the
best of luck in that as well
also want to highlight some of the
different community things that he's
been involved in in 2020 his be the
light campaign donated 1.4 million
dollars to covet relief efforts and
helped raise greater awareness of
increasing anti-asian racism during the
pandemic
he's also been appointed as unicef usa's
ambassador
and in that role he uses his platform to
champion children's rights and to also
help create more equitable world for
every child
his jeremy lin foundation also serves 22
000 youth over 22 000 youth and they've
done this through grants narrative
change community empowerment and racial
solidarity so again someone who has used
this platform and continued to be really
invested in the community and i'm
honored to welcome jeremy lin to the idr
podcast thanks for being here
thanks for having me i'm excited
of course and i'm glad to have this come
to fruition this is something we've
actually been talking about for quite a
while and took some time to get
everything coordinated so again grateful
to both of you for being able to uh to
be here today
but as my listeners know i always like
to just check in and see how people are
doing overall so want to just get a
sense of how you're both doing you know
at this point in time and also what your
day-to-day looks like um as much as
you'd be willing to share so jeremy
won't we uh go in reverse order and
start with you
um yeah i'm
i currently uh
last night was morning right now in
china and so last night we got to the
playoff bubble
um in nantung in china and so
um the whole season has been played in
different bubbles and these bubbles are
in different cities so we can only be in
the hotel and go to the gym and the
arena to compete and then come back
and so um we just got here our first
playoff game is in three days um and and
from there it's gonna be you know
just we'll see how you know how how far
we go but it's gonna be four round
playoffs um and
that's basically it um other than that
um it's been you know i've been
you know over here for the last
uh about nine ten months uh for this
season and so it's about to wind down um
we're about to see how the season
finishes um but
everything else is great i'm excited and
uh
you know i'm excited to talk with dr chu
and uh didn't realize
we had a lot of yale uh
yale background here
i wasn't warned of this as i came into
this podcast but uh
but uh
i think i'll i think i'll do my best now
you're going to hold your own
okay let's just keep it civil while
we're recording you know and then it can
all
it can all break down after that
we'll definitely appreciate it maybe
it's a reason we didn't warn you ahead
of time but like like i said i'm sure
you're gonna hold your own
and congrats on making the playoffs too
one one quick follow-up question to you
just as you were describing the bubbles
and all that what was it like
coming from here in the us not that you
haven't been in china before but
especially during this time and
transitioning into
a different place where there are
different protocols in place like how's
that process been for you
it's been it's been the most um
eye-opening experience
just to
just to get to china
the amount of work the amount of tests
things that you have to do
and i'll touch on this probably later in
but when i landed um
i was you know before i took off i was
negative i landed i was negative but on
my third day
of my 21 day hotel quarantine i tested
positive for kovit i still don't know
how and no one else on the flight was
positive and i ended up spending
11 weeks
in um isolated quarantine in a very
small room
in in the hospital um in the hospital in
the hotel trying to and so
when i say like the amount of i mean
we'll get into this later but it was
almost three months where i i did not
see the outside or breathe you know any
air from outside then wow um and you
couldn't do laundry you couldn't do
anything it was it was it was a quite an
experience and that definitely you know
we'll talk about mental health and all
that later but it's it's different but
then now here it's like a zoo almost
it's a zero tolerance policy and so when
you're you know in a country of 1.5
billion they basically have hardly any
cases um
very very few
um and they're typically all from people
who are flying in
and so it's also very different because
when you're walking around day to day
there's essentially no threat i mean you
are basically living in a bubble already
but then we're in a bubble inside of a
bubble yeah
wow that's a totally different setup
in a lot of ways so i mean i appreciate
you sharing that and giving people some
insight into what that experience has
been like too i think it's important for
us to realize how different things are
moving in different parts of the world
and then also like you mentioned some of
the uh the outcomes of that too but i'm
sure we'll loop back to that just in
terms of the mental health component of
that too as you mentioned so yeah
esther what about you how's life been
for you um these days especially you
know as an er doctor with everything
that we're continuing to navigate
yeah it's really interesting it's so
interesting to hear your story jeremy
because i think i mean there's the
element of my life that's about the er
and it's kind of not what you think i
mean we definitely have these surges
um and in oregon the most recent surges
the delta and the omicron were really
the most significant we dodged a lot of
the
of the
caseload from the early waves it just
didn't really hit oregon hard and then
we were hit
harder later but during the surges you
have a lot of empathy everyone's like
how are you doing is the er okay you
know but you kind of
mobilize your energy and your spirit for
those surges you know and what i think
what people don't realize is that
between the surges is actually really
hard too because that's when everything
comes crashing down on you i mean all of
that care
that was delayed you know people kind of
held off going to the hospital the
surgeries were put off
we used a ton of people resources and
then the search is over and all of that
kind of comes crashing down on you and
so um there's a piece that just was
published by a friend of mine in the
washington post
that was enumerating all the shortages
that we have in the emergency department
i mean supply chains are still affected
globally you know so we don't have
things like
sailing bags iv tubing the ability to
measure kidney function um a host of
medications that you use every single
day
every other day is a medication shortage
notice like this drug that you need that
you just think will always be there is
in short supply periodically different
types of ppe um the protective gear
still in short supply and then the
biggest one of course is the human
supply that we're running out of because
um we've lost you know a fifth or more
of our workforce many many nurses we're
always scrambling just to fill shifts
and so
i don't really remember what normal was
in the hospital before but we don't have
it during surges we don't have it after
surges um we're always diverting
patients away as a specialty hospital
and so
um there is that whole element and then
i think um
and then i think just like what's
striking as i listen to jeremy tell a
story about these like
incredibly rigorous processes to keep
people safe um and then i know you're in
a special nba bubble within that bubble
but i would say we are now in the u.s in
this really surreal environment where
people are completely not taking any
precautions you know we're like
there's still not adequate testing we
don't have surveillance programs in
those settings um i went to church the
other day and uh i was the my family was
the only one in masks you know with a
third of the congregation elderly
and people coughing and sneezing in a
closed space and we were just
it's uh it's not even suggested to be
careful and just not a lot of places in
the united states there's no concept of
the fact that there is a global pandemic
happening and we contribute to that with
our individual decision making so that
has been really demoralizing to see for
people who are
you know spending so much time in the
hospital and feeling the tail end of
that because of course there's a lot of
people who because of misinformation or
because of their medical conditions are
not able to be vaccinated to you know
have a good
good protections from coronavirus when
they're exposed so
um but that being said i feel very i
mean
i've been in the er this entire time um
i sometimes am not perfect about my ppe
somehow
i feel like i should knock on wood and
i'm cursing myself but somehow i have
not gotten covered yet and so you know
you you never take that for granted but
we've been really blessed my husband is
a physician also we've all we've both
been
um exposed many times um in our
community and at work and um so far have
our whole family has stayed pretty
healthy um so
just feeling very lucky to to this point
to have had that gift in our lives yeah
definitely a blessing in a lot of ways i
appreciate you just you know even
peeling back the layers to just give all
the perspectives i think so
much the time is easy for people who
aren't in the medical setting day to day
to realize what's happening in between
and all the challenges that are still
there um so i appreciate that level of
honesty and just the realness of it too
but like you said also the blessing of
not having contracted covert and just
being able to continue to walk through
in a lot of ways so thanks for that um
that perspective in a lot of ways and to
both of you just for you know the pccra
starting to bring out um i know there's
a lot we could unpack from just those
two comments that you both uh you both
made but one thing you know that we'll
do in the conversation too is also kind
of lean into the um the aapi space of
thanks to the asian asian american
pacific islander component and i did
just want to lead off just you know
acknowledging that that's a very
imperfect term
in a lot of ways even though that's what
we often use in these conversations so i
want to make sure that that was also a
point of emphasis and also you know just
with the expectation that i would
imagine our listeners are not going to
be expecting the two of you to speak on
behalf of the entire
racially diverse and uh
api communities um in that sense as well
but then also just having some insights
from your experiences too um just based
on the experiences you've had in your
own lives and interactions with family
and friends and things like that so now
that those are disclaimers but i also
just want to make sure that we really
you know keep things in context because
it's so easy sometimes to over
generalize but then it's also easy to
miss the important components that are
there so you know as much as we can kind
of hold both of those together i think
is important
but just to start out i know we'll get
into the mental health component a
little bit too just wanted to hear a
little bit about both of your
experiences in terms of growing up um
just that you in your communities
enlarge and how this aspect of being a
member of the aapi community has also
factored into that so esther actually if
we could start with you that'd be great
yeah sure um i am
the child of immigrants and my parents
moved here for grad school and then from
south korea what is now south korea and
then um never left um they kind of
thought they were coming just for my
father's education since the 1960s um so
this is a very common story for uh
koreans who had a similar background and
ended up having their kids here and then
never left so i was born here in the
united states and um and we lived in a
pretty um not ethically diverse
community on the west side of cleveland
and so i didn't grow up around a lot of
other koreans but we did go to korean
church for a while and so that was kind
of my exposure um so really the the you
know almost the entirety of my
experience with other asians was my
family um my immediate family and my
extended family but i think some of
those things really carried over nicely
too
to what i experienced when i was part of
a larger asian community from college
onwards
um i think in terms of some of the
topics we're going to
talk about later on in this or
throughout this podcast i think
um
you know just i
i don't ever remember mental health
being part of the conversation um i do
think um kind of being stoic and strong
and resilient and not
sharing your feelings too much was kind
of the ethos in my family we just
weren't warm it was very loving but
there was not a lot of warm fuzzy talk
um and certainly we never spoke about
what i now understand were
a lot of mental health problems across
our extended family you know you kind of
understood that somebody was ill and had
to go away for a while
or there was just that cousin who was
very shy and so never came out
when the rest of us were gathering and
you know only much later
when we started talking about these
things did we realize that we were we
weren't perfect what was happening is we
just didn't talk about things like
substance use
addiction mental health suicide those
things were all given
kind of euphemisms or completely not
addressed at all um and not talked about
so i think
even mentioning things like being
depressed or or needing therapy or
needing to be on medications those are
things i all learned on my own as an
adult and really had to reconcile them
against um kind of the implicit
values and practices that i learned
growing up yeah
i appreciate you sharing that and giving
giving that perspective that honesty
again as well
jeremy what about for you
um yeah i've had you know i
my uh background
is
uh pretty interesting um my
my grandparents um
born and raised in zlatjel which is uh
you know a province and in it and they
grew up in a city um very close to like
driving distance from shanghai
actually it was uh it was like 10
minutes away from the covet hospital
that i spent all that time at oh wow
and then my my parents
were born and raised
um
in taipei and then i was born
born and raised in california
and so um growing up is really
interesting because uh similar dr chu
like my
my main exposure to
other asians was
basically just at home or when i would
go to church and i went to i went to a a
chinese church
and so um
there it was like my asian circle and i
was also you know very fit in with how i
was raised and the culture that i was
raised in but then i grew up in palo
alto which is you know primarily white
community going to school um primarily
white
and harvard as well um just you know
um having that kind of school background
but then i would play basketball and
play competitive basketball playing in
the aau circuit
and so it felt like
that was primarily african-american and
so it felt like i had these three
different worlds that i lived in and
there was nobody that could really
understand
you know uh if i had someone in my in
one circle they might not understand
what it was like in one of the other
circles
and and there wasn't that much you know
carryover um and so aside from being at
home and at church i was always
kind of like um
labeled a little bit as like oh he you
know because people knew i played
basketball but there it was always like
yo he's asian but he's the asian
basketball player that's asian
basketball player and so never really
felt like i could you know it always
felt like i was like
you know for i guess a good reason they
respected that i could play basketball
but it was always kind of like
appreciation
um and so that was just something that i
kind of got used to but that was my
experience and
um very similar dr chu just a lot of
things weren't really talked about when
it came to mental health um even things
i had to learn about many things i
learned about um once i became a
professional basketball player and start
just have to tap into the mind and
support psychology a little bit more
um but it was very it was something
where even as of late when you know when
i started to go to therapy um
you know one of the initial questions
that you know um was asked me by one of
my parents like oh what's wrong like i
assure you like you don't you might not
need that and it was not ill-intentioned
at all it was just that's kind of
you know it's like oh no you don't need
it or you need medication or no no like
immediately it's like oh what's wrong
instead of it kind of being seen as
this is just a very helpful like life
tool that can be used to process
emotions to get through certain things
to be able to just be a better person
like you want to eat healthy you want to
work out you want to sleep well and you
want to do things for your holistic
well-being this is definitely you know
very important part that plays into that
yeah we appreciate you sharing then
again i mean there's so many overlapping
themes as you as you were talking
between um both of you just in terms of
navigating different spaces um being
here in the states you know having those
family connections and sometimes other
connections but then also kind of trying
to navigate between different cultural
uh groups as well but i mean it also
seems like the theme of that was just
the mental health component wasn't
really
talked about all that much now i'd say
you know
maybe it's an outsider that's kind of
been similar to some of my perceptions
as well so in college i didn't have a
couple of korean american um
roommates as well you know i did join
them at their korean churches at times
so i got to you know dabble here and
there and experience some of the culture
um it's funny i remember at one point
also playing and i um
i can't remember the name of the league
but there was a uh like a basketball
tournament at the university of north
carolina chapel hill for one of the
asian student associations every but
every team was allowed one non-asian
basketball player of course every
non-nation basketball player was black
so end up being those two groups i don't
know why i went there but
maybe jeremy talking about basketball
just reminded me of that that's its own
interesting phenomenon but just you know
kind of some of those cultural
um pieces that i've just you know seen
them navigate and have been able to
navigate with them as well but again
just that mental health piece i don't
ever remember that being talked about i
mean this is late 90s early 2000s and
then even the 2010s you know there were
lots of different
articles from different colleges where
people talk about you know the silent
struggles that students were having
often they were talking about asian
american communities black and brown
communities just that people were kind
of navigating and struggling and walking
through in silence not feeling like they
had any space to talk about it or they
would get some help at on campus but
then go home and feel like they couldn't
bring that same conversation up because
of all the different
ways that things were looked about uh
looked at so i mean i think a mirroring
a lot of what you all have said i'm just
curious if you've seen things shift in a
sense i mean jeremy talked about going
to therapy after you talked about
knowing what some of those things are
now have you seen things shift in terms
of acknowledgement in different aapi
communities or do you think it's more at
the individual level at this point or a
mixture of both
in my personal experience i've
definitely seen at least some level of
shift because
there's just a lot more people talking
about it um but maybe it's in certain
circles or or whatever but even within
my own family as well as some of a lot
of my friends as they start to talk
about it because mental health has
become you know one of the biggest
things since the pandemic that at least
certain areas are starting to make
pushes for in terms of exposure and
awareness and and so even you know in my
foundation just we talked to some kids
uh from from some of the grantees and
they're talking about and they're going
home and talking to their parents and
they're talking about how they need more
mental health resources in their schools
and
and it's definitely a different vibe
than when i was growing up and um and i
think even after you know
you know between me and some of my
friends and us talking about our mental
health with our parents i started to see
some different shifts happening i mean a
great example
that i had um was this past year i went
to eat with like six or seven people um
and they're primarily my agents in um in
china um and as well as you know uh
another athlete in the cba
another basketball player in the cba and
some friends and as we're all eating
we started to kind of talk about panic
attacks and so we had mentioned this
this concept of panic attacks and
immediately one person was like oh
really that that happens like
i didn't realize that like
wait so and he started asking these
questions and he was like man
they can't be that common
what ended up happening by the end of
the conversation
everybody went around and said that they
have had panic attacks multiple panic
attacks and and this group of friends
has been friends for over a decade
wow and they never talked about it and
never knew about it and never heard of
it and every single person went around
talking about how they had a panic
attack here this person struggled with
panic attacks occasionally or this
person had one here and and all of a
sudden it was like at the end of the
conversation um the guy was like my
agent was like
wow so it looks like i i might be the
only one at this table who you know um
you know
who has no idea what this feels like and
um and so it's just it was just really
eye-opening to me to realize like
because when you go through these things
you feel alone and you feel like you
don't know who to talk to there's no one
else that you can talk to about and so
that kind of really challenged me too
like to continue to try to use my voice
my platform more and to kind of fight
more for
mental health and and breaking that
stigma but i do think to answer your
question there we are headed in the
right direction at least yeah yeah i
mean that's a really helpful story to
hear i mean just the way that came about
too
uh just the awareness the level of
awareness because like i said everybody
was kind of going through an isolation
and the one person who had an experience
had no idea how common it was so
yeah that's really telling
esther have you seen things shift from
your perspective
yeah i'm i'm sort of going in circles as
i listen to jeremy's story because i i
do think we're still
so early in this process as an asian
american community um
as a global asian community
i mean i i i think of how
i mean i almost remember to the day or
at least the week or the era when
i had conversations with my friends
about david chang you know the chef
talking about his mental health and how
that was such a big deal when he was so
open and wrote about it in his book and
i remember mentioning it to a friend and
um and jeremy your name came up because
it's like
you know it's it's really cool to see
see even athletes asian athlete talking
about mental health like that and just
it's still in this era where when
somebody who's recognized and like
comfortable that you you know that you
relate to like you guys um
talking about this topic it's still one
of those like uh
people are surprised you know it's like
this in a wonderful way but i still hear
the surprise in people's voices it's not
like
oh yeah you know the 500th famous asian
person we know is talking about mental
health yeah they all talk it's like
still this wow moment because you don't
i still react with surprise and i mean
i'm much older than you are so i still
you know i am carrying with me kind of
the expectations and norms of a slightly
different generation um but i think for
me and my peers there's this
oh yeah we can talk about this now you
know it's like we've all been quietly
going to therapy but now we can talk
about this but i do see it more
um i do feel like the response is so
positive now that people are really
loving to see those messages um
i think from a researcher's perspective
because so much of my time is in
research when we talk about
asian american and pacific islander
health disparities around mental health
so much of it is just the numbers part
of it you know because of
the reluctance to report um
kind of collides with our poor data
collection
when it comes to any health problems
among
asian americans and pacific islanders so
i think you know when you think about
all the steps you need to take to
appropriately address a health problem
you have to like understand the problem
and collect the data and then devote the
appropriate resources to it and
develop good target outcomes and you
know you go through that whole process a
lot of times with asian american
mental health problems we're really
starting at the data collection
understanding the problem because it's
been so hard to
um
you know to get people to report
to seek help to you know register as a
as a you know as a dot when you're
looking at all the you know
the health services that are used for
example so um
i think i think some days i feel like
wow we've got so far to go to actually
feel like we're robustly addressing
mental health problems and there's times
where i feel like
there's so many you know increasingly
more inspirational stories and people so
hungry to hear those stories and feel
like okay you know like that
conversation can happen and people like
like jeremy and david are making these
huge it's like
you know
just like a single voice like that i
feel like has these huge ripple effects
it gives people permission to have those
conversations with their friends
to use people that you know are well
known to as kind of a starting point for
those conversations and that that didn't
happen when i grew up um never never i
can't think of a single
you know asian person that i looked up
to um who really used mental health is
like a major part of what they wanted to
talk about so
just
hearing it seeing it now is incredibly
moving and makes me feel like ah
you know there's hope yeah yeah i mean
it sounds like a breath of fresh air in
a lot of ways too
which is really really important i mean
you also highlight so many important
topics of where things need to move also
in terms of i mean you know some of the
maybe a year or two old two one to two
year old statistics saying that you know
23 percent of those in
can you actually seek out help so you
know jeremy even as you were sharing
your story part of what i was wondering
was like okay well all those people are
hearing that from each other for the
first time
one layer of me wonders like did people
actually seek out help
when they were going through those panic
attacks were people kind of
walking through that in isolation um and
so like i had a mixed feeling like i was
oh i'm so glad this is actually
happening in terms of conversations
people are realizing but i'm also hoping
that that
level of not having gone to that point
isn't happening on a larger scale in
some ways too you know not to me
pessimistic but that's kind of that's
kind of where my mind went hearing both
of those and so i wonder if you all
would be willing to talk about that
aspect too like are there ways that
you know we as a society or individuals
can help people move to that place of
actually wanting to seek out their help
which is still the stigma that really
needs to kind of be broken down first
like where do you see
some of the tension points and areas
where we can move that forward
i okay i'll go uh
leave it too open-ended
um i mean i i agree a lot with dr chu
that a lot of times when you say these
things there's a lot of shock and
[Music]
but then by the end of the conversation
it seems to always move in a good place
now whether you know so going back to
that story um
i kind of shared i was going through
therapy they were there with me when you
know not in the room but they were
waiting for me to get out when i went
through that 11 week period of being
confined a very small room
and
that's when i started therapy and so as
i was talking about it with them um
even you know there was mystery there's
there's mixed reactions like for some
people when they're talking about their
panic attacks like some people they
don't even know they're like oh
that's what's called a panic attack like
people are like oh you know another
friend was like i actually went online
and i researched and i was like what is
this what and why is this happening and
then that's how he came to realize those
panic attacks then you know other people
you know you know other people had you
know
have you know figured it out and tried
trying to do something about it and so
there's like a whole wide you know
there's an array of kind of how
everybody deals with it but the truth is
the reality is still that like nobody at
that table ever talked about with
anybody else at that table and didn't
know that everyone was going through it
and everybody you know and so for me
it's like again it's like
the first you know you're scratching the
surface of what it could or should be
and but at least now we're scratching
the surface yeah and and we're kind of
starting to bang at that door
um and so
and even for me when i share to tell
people like hey i started therapy i
almost have to like
you know my eyes are open but in my mind
i almost closed my eyes for the next
three seconds because you know every
time i say that a lot of people are like
or like wait what happened or like why
and it's like so i have to like blind
myself to like the shock otherwise it'll
make me feel a little insecure like oh
shoot something's wrong with me or why
am i doing i'm sure i need it like
and so even when i say it i kind of just
say like hey let them have the reaction
they're gonna have and then explain it
and talk about a little bit more in
depth and typically by the end and it's
kind of what you said on the beginning
of the podcast like authenticity always
works the best and if i just share from
my heart they kind of realize
oh wow like i probably struggle with
some level of anxiety i probably have
some of these you know foreboding
thoughts i probably process emotions
inadequately and experiences
inadequately that affect me in the long
term and
and so i think there's just a certain
level of again you're breaking through
that stigma of like
oh just because i go to therapy means x
y or z and and that's not where i'm at
so i don't need that i'm not like one of
them is kind of the mentality that some
people might have
um so
yeah i agree there's a long way to go
but at least we're starting and and
and it does seem like for the most part
i've had much more stories of like
people being very positive and receptive
about hearing about it than the other
way yeah
i think that's really great you're
giving people that grace too i mean
that's a fine line to walk giving them
the grace to kind of react but then also
protecting yourself in a sense too so
you don't start to second guess
the choices and decisions that you've
made which are also very very helpful so
i'm definitely commenting on that
because that's not easy good answer can
i can i ask i'm sorry i'm so sorry if
this is off topic but i'm really curious
about this 11 weeks um
did you know going in it would be about
that time period is it um was it
persistent
positive tests or symptoms or how did it
end up being that seems like a very long
time
yeah um well i think you know um
generally speaking the the the test
standards here um is about
you know i would say like 3x 3 to 4x
more strict in terms of like the
bacteria count and so
um
so the typical
i remember you know for me it was like
they were expecting
you know an on average two to three
weeks and i'd be fine
the problem is i i actually you know i
have a broken nose i broke my nose many
times from basketball and so
um the i couldn't flush out the dead
virus from my nasal cavity fast enough
and so i would have these like really
inconsistent tests
and so i would have a ton of dead
bacteria but it was getting picked up
and is enough to to be positive so what
was actually pretty crazy is i actually
you know there's a protocol for how you
test out and you have to get negative on
back-to-back tests and so i did that um
and i and and i had the hospital covered
test and then i had the cdc covet test
and i was fine and i went back into to
restart my 21 day hotel quarantine
and then on the seventh day i retested
positive even though you know for me i
was vaccinated and so
um there was a lot of
um yeah there
or sorry not bacteria virus um but the
the dead fire scene so that was the main
issue and so i had to go back again
and then stay there for
a few more weeks until
it came back completely clean it was um
yeah it was it was tough because like
this whole time my whole like signature
shoe launch my asia tour the start of my
season like everything that i had
prepared for i lost all of it and so
um i missed a third of my season and
and and and because i was vaccinated i
actually was asymptomatic for
of those 77 days i was asymptomatic for
the last like 60 something um
and and i never had too many symptoms
but
that's just how it goes and so um
really to be honest at that point it was
more about like my body i think i lost
like 15 20 pounds of like weight because
you know because i couldn't
work out and i couldn't get enough food
in my system
and then also just my mind like and and
that's where i'll be like very
transparent is like being in this tiny
little hospital room
and there's no windows that i directly
see outside and by the end it was like i
didn't even want to be awake um and so i
started to like
have this like
suicidal ideation of like man like and
my goal every day was to try to wake up
as late as possible
and to try to be as awake for as little
as possible and there are days where
like
i wouldn't even want to get out of bed i
would just be laying there and lunch
breakfast would be put there they would
the nurses walk and put breakfast and
then there's barack and put lunch and i
wouldn't even touch the food or open the
turn on the lights or and they're like
are you okay are you still sleeping and
it's just like i have no motivation i
can't stare at these four walls anymore
like
you know talking to myself all day
um and so that was when i really hit a
low point and i was like yeah i'm gonna
go to therapy um and i started therapy
um and in the past i've done like i've
worked with sports psychologists and
other things like that and so
um but this was like for me
as a person holistically and and uh and
so that was my experience it was
something that oh my gosh i'll never
forget for sure
wow
especially that piece where you
moved towards getting out and then got
yanked back in just must have been so
crushing to have that hope and then to
be back to square one i just because a
lot of i mean i think a lot of it was
just
i mean is about expectations you know
if you're if you're told from the outset
that it's going to be this amount of
time but to have it kind of
so uncertain the entire time must have
just been
crushing for your brain and your spirit
oh it was it was so crushing because the
thing is like i my first negative test
came on day 10. but i didn't officially
clear out of the entire thing until day
77 wow so for the last 67 days i'm
thinking like you know i'm almost there
i'm almost there and and again when i
when when i it's called fool young like
when you read test positive
i was so upset that like my luggage and
things i didn't even like there were
some very expensive some stuff where i
was like i don't even want it anymore
like
i was so angry and like i was like
sweating and like no this can't be
happening it was like a nightmare and
then like
you take the test at 5 30 in the morning
you need to wait until 9 00 pm at night
to get your results and so like the
whole day is like i'm just like and
every time a nurse walks by i'm like oh
the nurse just walked by are they coming
in oh it's bad news again and it's just
like it's just like this like thing
where on the outside looking in if i
tell the story now i'm like oh it
sounds bad but like to actually go
through it and to go through that for 11
straight weeks watching like all my hard
work and everything that i prepared for
like dwindle and watching my body like
just atrophy it was like
and like you said the expectation of it
up and down that was a killer if i came
into someone's just like it's gonna be
77 days i'll be like all right mentally
locked in i'm good i just got to find a
way to make it through i got a little
countdown but it's because i kept
thinking i'm right around the corner i'm
right around the corner and then it'll
be like just kidding
yeah
that's that's wild
it doesn't it does make me think too
about
it's something you said really early on
which is that mental health is just
health and i mean when you describe
going through that
i actually think it would be
abnormal if you didn't have an adverse
mental health consequence from that you
know
just kind of like
you're in a big car accident and it's
normal for you to be injured it's like i
don't actually know any person on earth
no matter how mentally strong they think
they are that could go through that
experience and not have you know just
like we talked a lot about that in
healthcare um how
in the pandemic when we were all like in
the hospital all the time we were
fearing for ourselves and our families
and watching these people drown in their
own secretions and you know um there was
so much uncertainty and we're scared and
people are like yeah you know if you
need it you we have these resources for
mental health and
at some point we are kind of like what
if we just say we're going to assume you
all need mental health because in this
circumstance
having an adverse symptom of mental
health is normal like who would not have
anxiety depression you know hopelessness
ptsd um so let's just
package in some mental health there and
if you don't need it you can opt out i
just feel like
yeah could we have a more proactive
you know especially for people who have
a hard time asking for it
um because of cultural reasons or you
know and norms it seems like maybe the
system can do a little more maybe
healthcare can do a little more to say
a normal symptom would be for you to
need some therapy
medication
support groups around now you know
but i mean that
your experience is i mean that's got to
be a very extreme
human experience to go through and i
cannot imagine that
yeah i mean everything i said is so
important
yes i mean jeremy as you're describing
that i mean all the circle like what we
do and studies basically you went
through all that i mean if you just add
on uncertainty over uncertainty over
uncertainty changing expectations lack
of motivation like those are all the
things like from a brain standpoint
that lead people to just that state of
being overwhelmed not wanting to to get
up get out of bed do things so i mean
exactly like esther was saying like just
needing to have those things in place
proactively i think is so important um
because in a lot of ways when we're
trying to look at those things in
laboratory settings um we're trying to
model chronic unpredictable stress as
the term that people use and that's
exactly like as you described that's
exactly what you were going through and
i think what what made it so difficult
so but also i mean i'm encouraged that
you took the time to say okay i am
actually going to look into therapy and
not just let this be the way it is and
to break through that as well
um i mean one question i also wanted to
ask you and have esther also chime in
what did because i can only imagine
there's so much you must have learned
going through that because it was so
difficult what are things that you've
taken from that that you're trying to
hold on to
moving forward because i would imagine
there are there are lessons and things
that you've learned in that moment that
you don't just want to keep there in
that moment
yeah i mean i think as it ties tying it
back back into all of mental health i
think
the lesson that i one of the lessons
that i learned is
when people decide whether they need
mental health support they're acting as
their own
doctor and so if you ask somebody who
smokes regularly like they'll be like oh
i'm okay like i can still play
basketball i still work out i can still
do and it's like yeah but if you if you
go on long enough like there's gonna be
adverse effects but they're their own
doctor and and what i realized with my
mental health was even in the past when
i had been more resistant to it it was
like
i don't and it's what dr chuja said like
no one comes out the same it's not
that's a fact it but it's whether you
realize it or not and so for me i
realized a lot of these experiences
were having
effects i just didn't realize it at the
time and so compartmentalizing it or
sweeping it under the rug does not count
as
like i'm okay because that will build up
and that will come back to get you
somewhere later down the road in a
different way
and and you have to be aware of that and
so
that's my like spiel on saying that like
when i went through this situation when
i got up i was like i'm finally out like
and i had this like breath of fresh air
like even just to feel the sun even to
be able to walk down the hall walk out
that door and walk down the hall or to
go down an elevator like these things
like i almost like when i my first time
walking down the street i almost was
freaking out i saw me all the lights the
cars because i was like there's so much
noise
and
and and i was just so excited to live
life and i was like okay that part is
over and then i got into the season and
in the season i started off really
poorly because
my body was inactive for three months
yeah
and i realized during the season i
remember after one of my worst games
i was like i'm gonna quit i just want to
go home like i don't want to play
basketball anymore and i never really
like i never had such after a bad game
like
i wouldn't normally respond that way and
i start to think like why am i so
lacking motivation why do i want out so
bad what is wrong with my mindset like
i've never been like this in my whole
career and that's when i realized okay
what happened there and the amount of
energy and the damage and the trauma
that i took
is affecting me now
even though i didn't expect it to happen
um and so i think that's really
important to know that like as you go
through these experiences like they're
building up and they're changing you and
they're changing the way you think and
they're changing like for me they
changed my persistence factor and my
perseverance because i just went through
something that you know and so again if
you ask me when i first got out i'd be
like dude i'm ready like i'm ready for
the season i'm ready for basketball like
i'm tired of every like i'm so excited
now the minute that basketball started i
realized dang i have almost had nothing
i'm running on an empty tank
and so
that's like
the one of the biggest things i learned
is that like if you're not processing
and healthily processing everything
you're going through it is continuing to
change the way your subconscious and the
way that you think
over and over and over again and and
that like i said you don't want to wait
until you know the person who's smoking
you know two packs a day does not want
to wait until the worst diagnosis to go
and do something about it right and so
that would be my one of you know maybe
an analogy i would use yeah what i
experience with my mental health yeah
that's great that's really really
telling in a lot of ways too i'm not
going to jump into all neuroscience even
though i have that tendency but just you
know just to mention like everything you
said like we often talk about you know
the experiences they change our brains
whether that's positive experiences
or challenging traumatic experiences
like what you had gone through and that
has effects and so you're seeing some of
that happen even though you weren't in
that situation anymore so i think it's
so important that you are paying
attention to that and i think that can
go a long way to empower people as well
we haven't talked about necessarily
within aapi communities but just trying
to help people think about like when
we're talking about mental health we
aren't actually talking about our brains
and our brains do react to different
situations and change in different
situations which impacts how we act in
other situations so i mean the way that
you brought that up i think is also
important but just again that level of
awareness that i think is huge
so i know we're running running short on
time this conversation definitely has
flown by esther i was just gonna
let you see if there's a last word that
you also want to uh to mention i'll pass
it back on to jeremy to close this up to
you but oh i'm still kind of sitting in
what you said because i think there's so
much truth to that so i i won't add on
to it i just think ev every word you
said um is what i wish i said better and
more often to
you know my patients and
anyone who listens when i message and
even my kids
so thank you for all that yeah really
important really well said
well there was so much that you all
brought in this conversation i felt like
this would have gone on for much longer
i know there's other topics we could
have pulled in as well but you know
perhaps maybe at some point in the
future we'll have a uh and i can't
promise any but another iteration of
this in some sense because i think
there's a lot of important topics um but
definitely appreciate you all making the
time to be here on this podcast
everything that you've shared so
honestly i mean just kind of walking
through what you've walked through but
also the hope that we have moving
forward as well um i know we didn't
touch on the faith component but that's
also a very a very big part of this
again for me just integrating the faith
with what we understand about the brain
psychology and our experiences i think
it's so important for us to all help
ourselves get to a better place as a
community not necessarily we're trying
to do ourselves but having the community
and having that divine intervention as
well so definitely appreciate both you i
know this is going to be an episode lots
of folks will get a lot from and
hopefully will continue to help break
the stigma even as people hear your
stories as well so appreciate appreciate
both you and the time you've taken to be
here today
thank you so much nee
oh thank you
[Music]